Applications, especially
enterprise-focused ones,
often have functionality
that is best configured
by IT admins rather
than the end user.
Think of server URLs, domain
names, whitelists, blacklists,
enabling encryption, even
usernames and passwords
for new users.
I'm Rich Hyndman,
and this is Part II
of my Android for
Work series where
I'll cover App Configurations,
Testing, and Launchers.
If you haven't seen Part I
yet, you can find it here.
We included new APIs in
Lollipop for our per application
policies.
They allow you to specify
features of your app
that are remotely
configurable by IT admins.
You specify the restrictions in
your Android project in an XML
file, and they're
made available to IT
admins in their mobile
device management console.
You can retrieve the
current values at run time
by getting an instance of
the restrictions manager
and calling get_application
restrictions.
Of course, if you do
that on initial launch,
you will find any existing
restrictions set by the admin,
but they can be
updated at any time.
So you should also register
for the relevant broadcast
so you're notified if an
admin updates the policy,
and then you can
load the new values.
Fortunately, you don't need
to remember any of that.
It's all detailed in the
Implementing App Restrictions
page, and there are sample
implementations available
as well.
Just head to
developer.android.com/work
for all the resources.
Testing your production
code is always tricky.
And regardless of whether
you're using app configurations
or not, it is good practice
to test your app in a managed
profile environment.
Android Work has put
together some useful tools
to help you out.
Firstly, you will need to
set up a managed profile
on your device or emulator.
You can do that with the basic
manage profile sample app.
Just click on Import
an Android Code Sample
in the Android
Studio launch screen.
It demonstrates how
to configure which
apps are available in
the managed profile
and which intents can cross
from one profile to the other.
Next, of course, you'll need
to install your application.
And once you have a managed
profile on your device,
any apps that you
sideload are installed
into both the profiles.
So then you need to
choose which profile
you're running the
application as,
and you do that with the User
Parameter on the ADB shell
commands.
To find the user
ID of each profile,
there's a List Users command.
The first number on each
line returned is the user ID.
If your app relies on the camera
or any of the default apps,
then it's worth disabling
them and testing.
Finally, a quick note for
developers of launchers.
Launchers replace the
default home screen
on an Android device,
and they provide
for awesome customizations.
And as you can
imagine, displaying
a view of two profiles
merged together
requires some minor updates.
As shown in the first
episode, corporate apps
now have a special badging.
Android 5 introduces
the launcher apps class,
which you can use to
find all the activities
available for the current user.
Just call
launchyourapps.getactivitylist
with a null package name.
And as managed profiles can be
added and removed at any time,
you'll also want to register for
the Profile Added and Profile
Removed callbacks to
keep the UI up to date.
Then, there are
methods for obtaining
badged versions of icons and
also especially badged text
for the content
descriptions to ensure
your launcher also
functions correctly
with the accessibility tools.
If your launcher
supports widgets,
there are also a
couple of new methods
in the app widget manager for
dealing with multiple user
profiles.
That's all.
Thanks for watching, and
let's get back to work.